yes we only have two episodes of Game of
Thrones left in things stories here to
take a quick look at next week's preview
so if you haven't seen it yet I've left
a link in the description because here
we go the preview begins with Daenerys
looking contemplative outside of the war
room in Dragonstone and it's no wonder
since last episode saw her not only lose
her dragon Ragle but also her confidant
miss and i it looks as though her small
battalion of troops who amassed outside
King's Landing has regrouped back at
Dragonstone and Tyrion here is a bit
apprehensive to approach her with all
that's been happening to Danny over the
last two episodes I'd approached slowly
- but if we know anything about her
she'll likely be fueled by rage Cersei
overlooks the city and you can see just
how far the castle is from the front
lines those little turrets are what we
see here holding giant ballista like the
ones you're on had on his fleet to
counter the dragons it's the same
ballista that were created by Qyburn in
season 7 - penetrated dragons thick
armor you can grab a quick glimpse of
Qyburn and the mountain in the
background and I wouldn't be surprised
if Aria and Clegane got behind the walls
of King's Landing before Cersei closed
them up after all Clegane will likely
battle it out with his brother who
caused those burn marks on his face
here we see Davos John and Tyrion behind
what's left of their army a ragtag group
of northerners unsullied and Dothraki by
the walls you can see the golden company
we'll get a better view of them later on
in the preview these guys look more
well-rested than their northern
counterparts in the throne room at
Dragonstone we see what appears to be
Tyrion and grey worm however some have
said it may be Varys they could be
coming to explain a new plan but judging
by Tyrians face here whatever Dany has
planned might not be what he envisioned
my guests fueled by the loss of Masson
died and Ragle Dany will decide to use
the dragon on King's Landing even if it
means the deaths of thousands of
civilians something Tyrion had been
fighting against since day one here we
see urine in the harbor at King's
Landing behind him the trailer later
hints that he's looking upward at drogon
which signals the Lannisters to arm
their crossbows but notice here these
are Lannister men and not Euron's I also
think there's some tricky editing going
on here
we have urine clearly on the see him
looking up in the sky is the sound of a
dragon wails then the men are me the
crossbow are on the cliffs outside
King's Landing hinting that drogon will
come from the sea and this shot here
could potentially be from somewhere
completely different within King's
Landing
because of the background wall here
which looks a lot more like the main
entrance perhaps most interesting is
Euron's brief look of surprise my guess
is that Danny wouldn't make the same
mistake by taking the fleet head-on
instead she'll either use the
positioning of the Sun and clouds to
manoeuvre drogon or perhaps she's had
him fitted with special armor that will
be able to resist the ballista either
way she'd be stupid to engage the fleet
without a new plan we also haven't seen
Yara Greyjoy and her fleet so I wouldn't
count them out as well with emilia
clarke saying episode 5 is bigger than
episode 3 my prediction is that we'll
see a lot more major deaths as the
northern troops eventually besieged
King's Landing we'll make our way closer
and closer to the red keep where we'll
likely to see battles between jaime and
cersei the mountain and Clegane and even
Qyburn will likely bite the dust
if drogon does die my guess is that
he'll have left dragon eggs since we
know dragons reproduce asexually in the
title sequence we even get four dragons
not three
perhaps hinting at the future of dragons
and Westeros we also don't know the fate
of a Laureus and whether she'll come
back next episode or the one after that
and I think it's a safe bet we haven't
seen the last of her that's my quick
breakdown of the preview be sure to LIKE
and subscribe since I have more Game of
Thrones videos on the horizon what do
you guys think will happen next episode
and if you'd like feel free to follow me
on twitter at thanks to a whitey until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much